INFLATION.
Tucker: YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME, THANK YOU.
Tucker: NO ONE EVER EXPECTED
THE ARIZONA RACE TO BE HOTLY
CONTESTED IN THE LAST 10 YEARS,
BUT THAT IS WHAT IT IS THANKS TO
KARI LAKE.
AND KARI LAKE IS A HUGE STEP
BECAUSE SHE COMES FROM THE
MEDIA.
THIRTY YEARS, SO SHE CAN EXPLAIN
IT.
SO IT SHOULD NOT SURPRISE YOU
THAT HER OFFICE WAS ATTACKED IN
A POLITICALLY MOTIVATED ATTACK.
POLICE AND BOMB SQUADS WORK
CALLED TO HER CAMPAIGN
HEADQUARTERS FOR A SUSPICIOUS
PIECE OF MAIL WITH WHITE POWDER.
AND THERE IS DEBATE OVER WHETHER
THE FBI IS TESTING.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON TONIGHT, KARI LAKE.
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF VERSIONS,
WHAT IS THE TRUTH?
>> THE TRUTH IS THAT WE HAD
DELIVERED AT OUR OFFICE A COUPLE
OF ENVELOPES THAT HAD WHITE
POWDER IN THEM, ONE OF THEM THE
STAFF OPENED UP AND REALIZED IT
WAS A PROBLEM, THREW IT IN THE
GARBAGE CAN AND THEN ANOTHER
STAFFER GRABBED IT AND THEN ALL
OF A SUDDEN WE HAD SEVERAL
PEOPLE EXPOSED TO IT.
AND THERE WILL A COUPLE OF BOMB
SQUADS, AND WE WERE TOLD THAT
THEY TOOK THEM FOR TESTING.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME, MAYBE
YOU KNOW MORE ABOUT IT THAN I
DO.
I HAVE BEEN BUSY CAMPAIGNING AND
WE HAVE BEEN MONITORING AND SO
FAR SO GOOD.
AND WE ARE JUST LUCKY THAT OUR
STAFFERS ARE OKAY.
Tucker: WHAT KIND OF COVERAGE
IS THIS IN THE STATE.
>> I DID SEE IT GET SOME
COVERAGE AND THIS IS MINOR
COMPARED TO WHAT I'M GOING TO GO
UP AGAINST WHEN I WIN THIS RACE.
AND I DON'T THINK THREATENING
LETTERS WILL BE THE WORST OF IT.
I THINK THERE'S MORE COMING, BUT
WE ARE READY FOR IT.
WE WILL NOT BE INTIMIDATED.
WE HAVE BIG ISSUES FACING US, WE
HAVE THOSE TERRORISTS IN
CONTROL.
I'M UPSET THAT THESE LETTERS
WERE SENT, I CARE ABOUT MY
STAFF, I KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE
MORE THREATS TO COME, AND WE
WILL STEER THEM DOWN.
BECAUSE WE WILL SECURE ARIZONA.
>> THANK